le département des yvelines au chevet de
ses étudiants à travers des mesures pour
lutter contre la précarité des
opérations d' aide alimentaire vont être
mises en place l'épicerie agora est
situé à guyancourt va devenir itinérante
l'iut de mantes-la-jolie va pouvoir
bénéficier du restaurant scolaire du
collège de gassicourt et le département
va aussi compléter le repas à un euro
dans les crous mise en place par l'état
c'est la prise en charge par le
département de l'euro qui reste ce n'est
donc pas prise en charge par l'état donc
nous allons faire ça avec le crous qui
est le gestionnaire à des restaurants
universitaires les étudiants vont aussi
bénéficier des aides financières une
rémunération en échange d'un travail
avec un partenaire ou à travers des
dispositifs départementaux existants
nous allons élargir à 500 le nombre
d'emplois pour accompagner les seniors
nous allons aussi favoriser cette sept
emplois étudiants en les rémunérant pour
faire du soutien scolaire auprès des
enfants qui nous sont confiées et nous
allons aussi créer une vingtaine de jobs
pour aider les associations alimentaires
ces mesures complètent les actions mises
en oeuvre par l'université versailles
saint quentin et le crous de versailles
on a aidé dans la première phase plus de
mille étudiants ou à peu près sur
dix-huit mille étudiants et donc on a
fait une aide qui s'élève je crois
surtout ces aides
autour de 260 milles euros au total le
département des yvelines va investir
plus d'un million deux cent mille euros
actuellement huit étudiants sur 10
disent avoir subi des préjudices à cause
de la crise sanitaire d'après un sondage
au doxa backbone